hey guys it is the 16th of sep tember
today my name is jeff mcdonald and
here's what mattered in gaming today
first our appear to be none too pleased
with the bbc's GTA TV movie the game
changes as they have some fairly
unflattering things to say about it
Rockstar called the program random made
up bollocks after the show aired on
Tuesday night you know as opposed to the
heavy realism you find in Grand Theft
Auto games the dev tweeted the BBC
directly saying this new renter ghost
isn't as good as I remember and was
basil brush busy what exactly is this
random made-up bollocks the BBC called
the game changes a factual drama
centered around the creation of the GTA
series as well as lawyer Jack Thompson's
appeal to the family of devin moore the
alabama man who shot and killed three
police officers in 2005 Thompson sought
to play some of the blame on the
developers of GTA as well as console
makers it seems that doom creator aids
software may have had a hand in helping
out the Thursday with fallout 4s gunplay
a recently published video which was
taken at e3 this year shows fallout 4
game director Todd Howard saying I won't
say anything bad about fallout 3 but we
wanted to not make any excuses for how
the action felt in a role-playing game
so the guns feel great we have aim down
sights you can play in first and third
person and then we have the VAT system
since if software is part of our company
the first thing we did was call them we
said all right we're going to do this
from scratch give us some tips you can
check out the full interview with Howard
in our story on gamespot fallout 4 is
true out on November 10 for pc xbox one
and ps4
the five nights at freddy's games just
keep on coming although this next one is
slated to be quite a bit different it's
an RPG developer Scott Cawthon took to
steam to announce the role-playing game
entitled five nights at freddies world
which is set to draw on its cast of
characters from the 59 games course on
added that there will not be a five
nights five as the story is complete
freddies world will let you create a
party from a selection of wizard and
horrifying toy critters and oddly enough
coughlin has confirmed that the game
will not be a horror title no release
date has been revealed at this stage but
a free demo will be released prior to
launch and it will be playable on pc
android and iOS let me know down in that
comment box if you're keen to play five
nights at freddies world you can have
the game spot or we've got attack on
Titan gameplay and the story on grow
home breaking download records that is
everything I have for you today as
always let me know what you cared about
Adele catchy same time tomorrow